and finally new role and I can't believe
I'm saying this but this country needs
to treat children better I know it's
crazy right me sticking up for kids it's
like Mike Pence fighting for gay
adoption even when I was a kid I didn't
like kids I remember being in
kindergarten thinking these people are
such children why am I even here we're
drinking milk and napping I could be
doing this at home but a few weeks ago I
saw that a second grade teacher in
Arizona had posted her pay stub and it
went viral probably because she's one of
the people we trust to care for and
educate our children and she makes three
hundred and twenty bucks a week we pay
such lip service to kids did the future
our greatest natural resource will do
anything for them and then we nickel and
dime their teachers if you really think
children are our future sure than the
people who mold their minds make more
than the night manager at Gamestop
there is a revolt brewing in the
teachers lounge these days in schools
all across this country and it's long
overdue time's up
meat pencils down
teachers are tired of being told what
Sarah Palin once said of a teacher that
her reward is in heaven maybe but the
rents due here on earth
[Music]
Elizabeth millage the teacher who posted
her pay stub wrote I buy every roll of
tape I use every paper clip I use every
sharpie I grade with every snack I feed
kids who don't have them how do people
even the burdened taxpayer justify this
we were all kids once we remember our
teachers you have those moments of early
learning imprinted in your brain a
teacher was your first mentor your first
role model if you grew up in Florida
your first lay
[Applause]
in West Virginia where the revolt
started teachers were just asking for a
5% pay raise not a lot but it helps when
you have to pay for your own paper your
own pencils and now your own bullets
here's an idea don't give the teachers
guns give them a living wage
they're not asking for the world just
enough of a race if they don't have to
drive an uber three nights a week
teachers it turns out do Drive ubers and
work as cashiers at Hardee's on weekends
and sell their blood plasma to make ends
meet it isn't supposed to be a side
hustle teaching in Kentucky teachers of
protesting governor Matt Bevins attempt
to reduce their pension fund Bevin said
the teachers have a quote thug mentality
he said it's about just straight up
wanting more than your fair share so
true you know when I think greedy the
first thing that comes to mind is a
public school teacher who takes the bus
to work and spends her tax refund on
crayons if we really cared about kids
would we give them an education
secretary who needs to stay after class
if he really cared about kids it
wouldn't be so hard for States to pass
laws against marrying them that's right
fun fact child marriage is legal in
every state what yes true in America
you don't even have to start your own
crazy religion have sex with children
you can just marry them and that's every
state not just the Waffle House dates
more than 200,000 children were married
in America over the past 15 years some
as young as 10 and 24 states there is no
minimum age to marry its me to 4
Hollywood but we're okay with this and
again this is coming from me me somebody
who has no use for children and don't
even get me started on babies no I don't
want to hold your little Roswell alien
[Applause]
some people call kids gifts from God I
call them reasons for ear plugs I don't
like seeing kids I don't like hearing
kids I do not like kids on a plane I do
not like kids on a train but as much as
I personally can't stand to be around
them I would rather American children be
well-educated productive contributing
citizens as opposed to what they
otherwise might become useless burdens
on society